ces derniers mois le colis de 19 a
beaucoup reculé dans de nombreux pays en
europe comme en france et en suisse
c'est une excellente nouvelle
il ya quelques mois ça semblait très
loin d'être gagné mais ailleurs dans le
monde et en particulier en amérique du
sud en amérique du nord moyen orient et
au tour de l'inde
le coc vite de 19 continue à gagner du
terrain de manière très inquiétante qui
encore de nombreux pays semble avoir
renoncé à imposer déconfinement car ceux
ci devenait trop dangereux pour les
populations défavorisées en restituant
les libertés ces pays s'expose ainsi à
une explosion des cas de kobe 19 et ça
c'est aussi une très mauvaise nouvelle
pour les pays qui sont parvenus à
maîtriser la pandémie en effet
l'économie étant devenu mondialisée les
chaînes de production qui nous
permettent d'avoir accès à des biens de
base en europe dépendent fortement du
bien-être économique et des pays où ces
biens sont produits pis encore la
faillite d'un fournisseur ou d'un client
dans d'autres pays peut être critique
pour des entreprises européennes ce qui
pourrait alors mettre en danger la
survie de ces entreprises et l'emploi de
leurs nombreux salariés
mais ce n'est pas tout une pandémie
incontrôlée sur d'autres continents
c'est aussi une augmentation des risques
pour tout le monde
plus le score de est présent chez nos
voisins plus le risque qu'il se propage
jusqu'à nous écran combattre locaux
vides 19 est aussi et surtout un effort
global
enfin et peut-être surtout même si
locaux vides de 19 est actuellement
moins actif sur notre territoire qu'il
l'a été en avril il n'a absolument pas
disparu il pourra repartir à tout moment
surtout si la population baisse trop sa
garde
nous sommes très très très très loin
d'avoir éradiqué la maladie
d'autant qu'une étude sérologique
récentes sur soixante mille espagnol
suggère que seulement 5% de la
population serait immunisée
on est visiblement très loin de
l'immunité de groupe même dans ce pays
très violemment frappée par le cos vide
ainsi tant que le colis de 10,9 n'aura
pas été éradiqué les restera une menace
importante en fait dernièrement la
pandémie semble possiblement redémarrer
dans certains cantons en suisse et dans
certains départements en france
en fait le scénario
fu dans les années à venir est loin
d'être très réjouissant en l'absence de
solution efficace pour combattre
qu'ovide 19
il risque d'être essentiellement
impossible de s'en débarrasser auquel
cas il nous faudra constamment
surveiller nos gestes barrière le port
du masque et d'autres mesures comme les
tests systématiques des individus
symptomatique
en effet à l'instar de nombreuses autres
maladies et comme primeur l'illustrent
formidablement bien dans cette
excellente vidéo
il semble probable que l'immunité aux
que vides soit imparfaite
elle pourrait disparaître après 10 ans
et peut-être même après seulement un an
pour l'instant tout ça est bien sûr très
difficile à savoir notamment parce que
bien sûr personne n'est encore vécu un
an après avoir attrapé le virus
mais alors on pourrait avoir une
augmentation constante de la population
susceptible d'attraper et surtout de
propager le virus ce qui permettrait aux
convives de toujours disposer de vecteur
pour se répandre en fait et les modèles
épidémiologiques suggèrent qu on aurait
alors probablement un équilibre où cette
augmentation sera contrebalancée par la
propagation du virus qui immuniserait
ainsi les nouvelles victimes du coc vide
le coc vide 19 deviendrait alors ce
qu'on appelle une maladie endémique les
maladies endémiques sont celles qui
persiste parce que notre immunité
imparfaite ou le flux de nouveaux
individus pas encore exposés à la
maladie fait que la maladie pourra
toujours trouver des hôtes pour se
propager
notez que comme le montrent ces
excellente simulation de nikki caisse en
collaboration avec l'épidémiologiste
marcel s'arrêter de le pfl la
saisonnalité d'une maladie aggrave les
pic d'infection typiquement s'il se
trouve que le taux de reproduction
effectif
rt du coc vide est inférieure en été est
supérieur en hiver on assisterait alors
une diminution des cas en été qui
s'accompagnerait malheureusement une
augmentation de la fraction des
individus susceptibles
dès lors quand vient l'hiver on pourra
assister à des pics dévastateur qui
surchargerait les hôpitaux et ça c'est
bien sûr un énorme problème puisqu'une
mauvaise prise en charge du co vide mais
aussi d'autres maladies c'est aussi et
surtout un plus grand taux de mortalité
bref dans les mois les années et même
les décennies à venir à moins d'une
intervention médicale efficace il faut
malheureusement s'attendre à ce que le
coc vide devienne une nom d'amy et qu'on
en subissent constamment ou
régulièrement les effets dévastateurs
l'histoire de l'humanité est plein
d'endémie catastrophique l'une des pires
ennemis et celle de la variole small
boxe en anglais maladie absolument
terrible qui tue 30 % des individus
qu'elle infecte
mais ce n'est pas tout pour les 70%
restants la variole elle est souvent des
traces horrible on estime ainsi qu'au
xviiie siècle trente pour cent des
individus infectés survivaient mais
perdait la vue suite à leur combat
contre cette maladie atroce et je ne
parle pas des conséquences sur
l'apparence physique et alors je vais
être sympa contrairement à équiper dia
je ne vais pas mettre d'image de la
variole
oui parce que ça peut heurter les âmes
sensibles tout cas moi cela me heurte
beaucoup j'ai un peu eu un mal fou à
lire les pages wikipedia cause de ces
images au xxème siècle ce sera autour de
300 millions d'humains qui aurait
succombé à cette maladie atroce et
pourtant petit à petit nous avons réussi
à combattre et même à anéantir l'endémie
de variole aujourd'hui la variole a
disparu nous l'avons éradiquer nous
sommes passés de centaines de millions
de morts au 20ème siècle à 0 au 21ème
siècle
c'est absolument incroyable quand on y
réfléchit et tout ceci repose sur une
solution qui aurait sans doute paru
miraculeuse pour les habitants du xviiie
siècle
nous avons inventé la vaccination la
vaccination massive de la population
mondiale a ainsi sauvé des centaines de
millions de vis par siècle
incroyable
le chemin vers la taxe
massive n'a tout
été un long fleuve tranquille il a
d'abord fallu découvrir l'idée de la
vaccination
on trouve des traces des prémices de ce
principe il ya plusieurs siècles
en chine les chinois ont certainement
constaté que les individus qui ont
survécu à la variole devenait immunisés
contre cette terrible maladie
certains chinois ou alors eu l'idée
d'inoculer les individus sains avant
qu'ils ne soient infectés ou par le
d'inoculation dont le cas de la variole
de vario lisation pour effectuer la
périodisation les chinois récupérèrent
des morceaux de pustules sur des
individus infectés par la variole mais
relativement peu malade puis il
injectait indirectement des traces de
ces pustules dans le nez des individus
sains ces individus sains de verre alors
malade mais la plupart du temps ils ne
subissent qu'une forme faible de la
maladie et surtout après avoir survécu à
la variabilisation les individus ainsi
traités devenait immunisés contre la
variole
ceci dit l'opération était loin d'être
sans risques même après des
améliorations successives de la
variabilisation entre 1 et 3 pour cent
des individus ainsi inoculé décédèrent
suite à la barre ionisation oui c'était
super chaud le traitement préventif
contre la variole était lui-même
mortelle du cap sur port tel que le
convive 19 et donc vous imaginez le
dilemme horrible que cela posait par
exemple aux parents ils pouvaient soit
parier sur la variabilisation et prendre
le risque que l'enfant meurt tout de
suite où ils pouvaient parier sur le
fait que l'enfant n'attrape jamais la
variole auquel cas s'il attrape un jour
il aura une plus grande probabilité de
mourir et surtout vous imaginez le
traumatisme pour un parent de voir son
enfant mourir suite à une vario lisation
l'enfant serait il alors décédé à cause
du parent en 1760
le mathématicien daniel bernoulli
s'intéresse à justement à cette question
avec une approche formidablement
bayésienne montra alors qu en
généralisant la pratique de la
réalisation par exemple en la rendant
obligatoire n'augmenteraient l'espérance
de vie de la population de trois ans
même si bien sûr si on faisait ça du
coup c'est voudrait dire qu'une minorité
de parents qui aurait ainsi choisi ou
qu'on aurait alors forcé à effectuer une
vario lisation pour leurs enfants ses
parents aurait alors vu leurs enfants
succombé suite à cette décision
c'est là que le principe qui consiste à
juger le pari pas le résultat est
critique
à garder en tête ce n'est pas parce que
votre enfant meurt suite à une décision
de variabilisation que la décision de
valorisation était mauvaise oui car la
décision était prise avant qu'on ne
sache que la variole isation serait
mortel pour l'enfant au moment de la
décision
la mort de l'enfant suis qu'à la
valorisation était en fait peu probable
mais bien sûr raisonner en termes de
paris c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
plus facile à dire qu'à appliquer en
pratique en pratique quand notre pari
est perdant bien encore quand le pari
d'un autre est perdant c'est si tentant
de penser qu'il s'agissait
nécessairement d'un mauvais pari
en 1796 le génialissime médecin edward
jenner changea complètement la donne en
inventant le vaccin plutôt la vaccine
par le vaccin avec la vaccine jenner
entendu dire que ceux qui attrapent et
la vaccine une maladie qui touche les
vaches et peut se transmettre aux
humains
ces individus ayant eu la vaccine
devenait alors immunisés contre la
variole
or la vaccine est en fait très peu
dangereuse pour nous autres humains
jenner testa alors sa théorie en
inoculant un jeune enfant de 8 ans avec
la vaccine comme attendu le jeune enfant
tomba malade il eu un peu de fièvre mais
il finit par guérir puis john hurt est à
l'immunité du jeune enfant en infectant
avec la variole d'un autre individu
malade oui niveau éthique de la
recherche médicale à l'époque on n'avait
pas tout à fait les mêmes standards
qu'aujourd'hui de façon presque magique
le jeune enfant ne subit même pas les
symptômes de la variole ils étaient
immunisés contre la variole jenner
répète à cette expérience de nombreuses
fois et constata encore et encore que la
vaccine immuniser les individus ainsi
traitées contre l'endémie dévastatrice
de variole
en 1958 il suit à
ministère de la santé de l'urss le ms
lance un plan d'éradication de la
variole une collaboration internationale
extraordinaire est lancé contre cette
endémie après deux décennies a testé
tracé isolé et vacciner toutes les
régions à risques à investir massivement
dans des traitements et des suivis
médicaux et à venir en aide à de
nombreuses régions défavorisées ou la
variole persistait en 1979 loup m s
annonce un triomphe inédite dans
l'histoire de l'humanité une endémie
dévastatrice fut éradiquer la variole
avait disparu
à titre personnel j'ai découvert cette
histoire de la variole seulement très
récemment et je trouve cela fort dommage
je ne vais sans doute pas me faire des
amis en disant ça mais je trouve
personnellement que l'éradication de la
variole est un succès de coopération
internationale plus fantastique et
inspirant encore que d'avoir envoyer des
astronautes sur la lune ou que d'avoir
construit un accélérateur de particules
à genève même si vous savez que c'est
cool d'avoir construit un accélérateur
de particules à genève mais c'est pas
aussi cru que d'avoir éradiqué une
maladie aussi terrible que la variole il
me semble ainsi que l'humanité se
porterait beaucoup mieux si au lieu de
prendre systématiquement l'exemple des
missions apollo comme triomphe de
l'ingéniosité humaine comment on fait
d'ailleurs malencontreusement dans notre
bouquin le faible chantier ou prenaient
davantage l'exemple du triomphe de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé face
à laon démis destructive de variole
après tout parmi ces évènements un seul
peut se vanter d'être une coopération à
l'échelle de toute l'humanité d'avoir
sauvé des centaines de millions de vies
et d'avoir grandement améliorer la
qualité de vie de milliards du nord oui
car une population qui n'a plus à
souffrir et à se soucier de la variole
c'est aussi et peut-être surtout nos
populations qui réduit drastiquement ses
coûts sanitaire et psychologique a
constaté la souffrance et la mort est
proche
c'est une population qui sera beaucoup
plus libre de s'occuper de son
développement économique de son
éducation et peut-être même de son
impact écologique en effet de façon très
contre intuitives comme l'expliquent
très bien looking glass universe des
tests randomisée contrôlée suggère que
soigner des maladies semble être la
manière la plus efficace de permettre
aux enfants d'aller à l'école dans les
pays défavorisés car ce qui empêche les
enfants d'aller à l'école et de recevoir
une éducation c'est souvent le fait
d'être malade
les tests randomisés contrôlés ont
montré qu'en soignant ses enfants la
présence scolaire augmente à ceux qui
conduisaient à toutes sortes d'autres
effets secondaires indésirables comme
l'émancipation des jeunes filles une
diminution du taux de natalité et une
réduction du coût de l'impact
environnemental
dans cette optique l'éradication de la
variole est vraiment un triomphe
spectaculaire de l'humanité et c'est
peut-être malheureux que quand on pense
qu au triomphe de l'humanité
ce n'est peut-être pas l'exemple qui
nous vient en tête en premier c'est en
tout cas il me semble beaucoup trop
rarement l'exemple qu'on cite et ça
c'est peut-être une erreur qu'on commet
en communication scientifique
en effet si triomphe de l'humanité il
m'est plus souvent avec variole
éradiquée serait alors peut-être plus
immédiat de se poser la question de
l'éradication des autres endémie
dévastatrice du financement massif de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
y arriver et des bénéfices incroyables
d'une vaccination massive de la
population mondiale
vu toute cette histoire vous vous dites
peut-être dû
ou qu'il suffira de trouver un vaccin
contre le coc vie de 19 pour éradiquer
cette terrible maladie
malheureusement et indiqué le codis 9
sera probablement beaucoup beaucoup plus
difficile que d'éradiquer la variole la
variole bien que très mortelle et
contagieuse était en fait relativement
facile éradiquée premièrement on connaît
un vaccin est assez efficace contre la
variole en effet il suffit d'être
vacciné une fois pour obtenir une
immunité qui dure cinq à dix ans dans le
cas de co vide pour l'instant il semble
encore loin d'être dit et peut-être même
peu probable qu'on arrive à trouver un
vaccin avec cette efficacité dans l'émoi
dans les années peut-être même dans les
décennies à venir
deuxièmement la variole cause
systématiquement des symptômes et mieux
encore des symptômes très spécifique à
la variole
il est donc beaucoup plus facile de
détecter des foyers épidémiques pour les
isoler et prioriser la vaccination de
leur région mais aussi et surtout les
dès lors beaucoup plus facile de
vérifier l'éradication de la maladie
a contrario le coc vie de 19 et
difficilement discernables d'une crypte
et surtout beaucoup d' infecté par le
comité 19 demeure asymptomatiques
identifier les foyers de contamination
par locaux vides 19 et déjà un sacré
défi en tant que tel enfin et surtout en
troisième lieu la variole n'affecte que
l'espèce humaine
a contrario locaux vides 19 semblent
provenir d'animaux comme les chauves
souris
et si tel est le cas ça voudra dire que
même si on éradiquer le virus sascoc de
kick aux locaux vides 19 chez les
humains ce virus ou des variantes preuve
que ce virus persiste aura très
probablement à exister dans les
chauves-souris ce virus pourrait alors
sauter à nouveau sur des humains à tout
moment dit alors des chauves-souris
qu'elle serait une espèce réservoir
malheureusement les techniques
d'éradication de la variole seront
certainement insuffisant pour éradiquer
les locaux vides 19 autrement dit il
semble probable qu'on est encore à se
préoccuper de pic de contamination des
gestes barrières et douadi station
physique dans les mois à venir pendant
les années à venir voire possiblement
dans les décennies à venir
malheureusement le coït 19 ne semble pas
prêt de partir
ceci dit à l'instar du virus contre la
grippe
les vaccins partiellement efficace
contre les copies du 19 pourrait déjà
nous sauver de bien des maux typiquement
aussi un tel vaccin pouvait immunisés
30% de la population pendant six mois ce
serait déjà un outil intéressant pour
réduire les effets
la stat heures de cette maladie et s'ils
pouvaient immunisés 70% de la population
pendant un an on pourrait peut-être s'en
sortir avec des vaccinations annuel
essence d'intervention comportementale
majeur mais pour en arriver là il va
falloir d'abord investir massivement
dans la recherche d'un tel vaccin est
dans la communication scientifique de
qualité pour promouvoir l'acceptation de
tels vaccins par le grand public
s'il ya une chose que j'aimerais que
vous reteniez aujourd'hui c'est le
succès ahurissant de la vaccination
notamment dans le cas de la variole
cette technologie fantastique qui
paraîtrait miraculeuse et magique à des
civilisations passées nous a permis de
sauver des millions de vies par an et
même d'éradiquer des endémies
dévastatrice et dans la lutte contre le
comité 19
cette technologie pourrait jouer un rôle
clé pour réduire drastiquement les
besoins en gestes barrières et andy
sensations physiques
cependant nous ne disposons pas encore
de sa technologie pour le coc vite 10,9
pour disposer d'un vaccin efficace
contre le coc vite 19
il va d'abord nous falloir soutenir la
recherche scientifique et les essais
cliniques
puis nous faudra aussi et surtout
vérifier autant que possible la sécurité
de tels vaccins
il s'agit là sans doute de l'un des plus
grands défis pour le futur de l'humanité
à court et à moyen terme